en este vídeo pensaremos en el teorema
del valor extremo que como veremos es un
poquito más de sentido común que de
cualquier otra cosa pero en todos estos
teoremas siempre es muy divertido pensar
en cómo están enunciados y porque están
enunciados de esa forma y eso nos dará
mucha más intuición al respecto entonces
lo que dice el teorema del valor extremo
así se llama teorema del valor extremo
nos dice bueno considérate primero una
función f que sea continua muy bien
tienes una función continua pero debe
ser continua en un intervalo cerrado a b
y cuando decimos un intervalo cerrado a
b y que por eso ponemos estos corchetes
estamos diciendo que estamos incluyendo
a llave en este conjunto muy bien
entonces tomando una función continua en
el intervalo cerrado podemos garantizar
que existen
valores máximos y bueno existen valores
hay un máximo
y mínimo absolutos
valores máximo y mínimo absolutos
muy bien y por supuesto estos valores
son máximo y mínimo absolutos de f en
nuestro intervalo cerrado a b muy bien
entonces qué es lo que quiere decir esto
esencialmente pensemos en hacer un
dibujo
digamos ahí tenemos el eje y
el eje x muy bien y aquí voy a pintar
una gráfica digamos que por aquí andea y
digamos que el valor de a es este muy
bien aquí está cuánto vale
efe digamos que por aquí anda ve y que
esto vale fpv muy bien
ahí está
esto es lo que vale efe dv muy bien
entonces la idea es pintar la gráfica de
esta función continua que que en
realidad va a ser bastante arbitraria
pero debe ser continua entonces por
ejemplo puede ser
algo así
y luego baja
muy bien
entonces tenemos esta gráfica de la
función continua y bueno en realidad lo
que estamos diciendo es que podemos
encontrar podemos encontrar un máximo y
un mínimo absoluto es decir aquí está
nuestro mínimo absoluto no hay un valor
más chico que ese muy bien entonces este
es el valor más chico fcc para algún c y
el otro nos dice que va a haber un valor
máximo absoluto es decir no va a haber
nadie en el intervalo ave que bajo la
función sea más grande que este valor
muy bien entonces aquí existe un d el
otro digamos será c y c es el mínimo
absoluto de la función y d es el máximo
absoluto entonces en realidad cómo
podemos reescribir este teorema es de la
siguiente forma podemos garantizar que
existen
y de elementos de nuestro intervalo a ve
muy bien tales que tales que que cumplen
que fcc es el valor más chico entonces
es menor o igual que fx verdad donde x
puede ser cualquier valor de este
intervalo pero al mismo tiempo cualquier
valor que toman la función en este
intervalo debe ser menor o igual que
nuestro máximo absoluto muy bien
entonces esto es para todo para todo
punto x en nuestro intervalo cerrado a
coma b
esto es digamos el teorema del valor
extremo ya expresado en términos
matemáticos entonces nuevamente nos dice
que podemos encontrar dos valores uno en
donde va a alcanzar el mínimo absoluto
quiere decir que la función no puede ser
más chico que ese valor y además va a
encontrar o vamos a poder encontrar otro
valor de en este intervalo tal que la
función en ese punto no puede bueno más
bien alcanzar su máximo ya no puede
alcanzar un valor
grande muy bien y realmente esto sirve
para cualquier gráfica de una función
continua muy bien aquí por ejemplo este
en realidad aquí estaba
efe de a verdad esto valía de fedea pero
pues puedes tú imaginarte cualquier tipo
de función por ejemplo podríamos pintar
una línea recta verdad y ahí de todos
modos vamos a poder encontrar un mínimo
y un máximo puedes incluso pensar en una
función constante puedes pensar en una
función constante en donde el mínimo se
alcance en cualquier punto hay de hecho
hasta acá hasta acá llega de verdad
entonces esto llega hasta acá entonces
realmente no nos dice cuántos puntos
máximos absolutos ni cuántos mínimos
absolutos tiene tampoco nos dice si hay
un número digamos
finito o si hay una infinidad de esos
valores pero al menos garantizamos su
existencia y este teorema no lo voy a
demostrar pero vamos a tratar de
familiarizarnos muy bien entonces con
esto
ejemplos tenemos ya al menos tres
figuritas en donde es una función
continua y vemos dónde se alcanza el
mínimo y el máximo en la función
constante por ejemplo puede ser en
cualquier lado ok entonces lo que te
invito es ahorita que hagas tú una pausa
y trates de pensar en una función que no
sea continua es decir vamos a tratar de
ver por qué nos piden que sea continua
así que piensa en una función continua
más bien que no sea continua en un
intervalo cerrado y que por lo tanto no
haya valores máximo y mínimo ok entonces
por ejemplo podemos pensar en este
siguiente ejemplo
digamos vamos a pintar nuestros ejes ahí
está el eje x y el eje y muy bien y no
se podríamos poner digamos que aquí está
el ahí como lo estamos incluyendo porque
era un intervalo cerrado entonces vamos
a ponerlo así digamos que esta función
va subiendo va subiendo va subiendo pero
justo donde va a alcanzar su valor
máximo ahí no va a estar definida tiene
un agujero y luego va a bajar va a bajar
va a bajar y dónde va a tener su valor
mínimo tiene un agujero muy bien y
vuelve a subir entonces porque podemos
decir que éste no alcanza ni un máximo
ni un mínimo absoluto claramente éste no
es continua verdad tengo que despegar el
lápiz ong en mi caso la pluma para poder
terminar de pintar la gráfica entonces
por ejemplo para este valor para este
valor
para este valor nosotros sabemos que
aquí no está definido pero si nos vamos
aproximando a ese valor
podemos ir alcanzando valores cada vez
más altos pero nunca vamos a alcanzar el
máximo porque ahí no está definido muy
bien entonces esa es la idea de por qué
cuando no es continua el teorema no
siempre es cierto muy bien no siempre
puede haber ocasiones en donde si ahora
la otra pregunta es porque nos piden que
sea un intervalo cerrado qué pasaría si
por ejemplo fuera un intervalo abierto
entonces vamos a poner otro ejemplo en
donde ahora aquí
no lo estemos considerando y tampoco ver
y podríamos pensar en un ejemplo
sencillo digamos una línea
la línea
ahí lo tienen muy bien entonces mismo
ejemplo que aquí el valor mínimo se toma
en a muy bien entonces como nosotros no
lo estamos considerando en el intervalo
podemos aproximarnos tanto como queramos
pero nunca vamos a llegar al valor
mínimo tampoco al valor máximo verdad
que es justo el que toma b entonces nos
podemos ir aproximando cada vez más pero
nunca nunca llegar al valor máximo así
que hasta cierto punto este es un
teorema muy intuitivo y siempre es bueno
saber por qué nos piden esas condiciones
en las hipótesis del teorema